the Joe Rogan experience so when when
you're torn with this music now and
you're [ __ ] with it and you're
switching things up like when we you
decide that it's time to write some new
[ __ ] well you just tour and then stop
touring and then well I'm always writing
poetry do I anymore I used to sit down
with a guitar and like I'm gonna write
this song you get like a part in words
and you find meter and phrase I've
discovered I'm really just a poet it's
easier to write the words out and craft
the meter and phrase to those words
musically in the studio I would say both
all the other three records I would
probably wrote half of them while you go
in to make the record you think you have
the songs and you realize that those
songs are not supposed to be a part of
this record I would go home at night and
write songs that fit that record where I
would come in with parts like sailor's
gotta had a lot of parts of music they
get pieced together in the studio and
these guys probably all thought I was
[ __ ] insane for a scared verge of
death because he usually I want to hear
the songs like I got some notes you know
but really the music happens you lock
yourself in that room with the right
people for a matter of days and you just
keep going until it's done and you have
ideas in the moment but now I don't even
pick a guitar up to write I just write
what I want to say what I'm feeling and
then these guys you know push and
encourage and motivate me to try to do
the other thing as well as I'm able go
sorry are you writing longhand are you
riding on a ya know I write always write
it it was right right in your hand again
I have notepads and I'll go through and
just scribble out sections or pick this
can fit with this this record was varied
deconstructed I guess we did some loops
and we were like record riffs in a
certain key and then record that same
riff and every other key so I could take
it and chop it to a loop and make it
super precise like a hip-hop album and
if some stuff was just live as [ __ ] you
know and you just having fun we had a
lot of fun mm-hmm
the improvisational part of it sounds
terrifying but awesome
that's what Austin's what you want I
mean sometimes you get something if it's
a mulatto cook or something the first
take it's usually the one you keep you
know yeah when you go back and try to
make it perfect it sounds cool weed and
we knew that having done this before so
with these sessions we win it that was
the only rule there was no second
guessing or indecision hence the samurai
films on the wall
hmm cuz like in a sword fight you got
one [ __ ] move you know I mean that
was like that was the mo for these
sessions like the first thing is that
matters the right thing it's the thing
so when you're doing that new recording
things do you pause and go listen to it
and play it again how do you how do you
guys do it sometimes it depends you know
if it sounds cool like Bobby said then
you probably keep it and if you're like
and it didn't really work try something
else yeah most of his solos on the
record really first second take I mean
Chuck I don't think I've ever [ __ ]
punched a single thing in Chuck's life
Chuck's perfect he just kills it he's
the man Bob I've got a bunch of video
somewhere computer Lee I made him record
all of his solos with a jointness man
like the intro thing they're like we
need a thing for this and I was like
well I needed
I need a doobie and I smoked it and I
just played them I have some of those
videos to on myself to that point on
every time he played he had a jointness
Mouse I was like not just thinking about
the music it was like so you know
anything to just settle it was it was
pretty fun I mean we're kind of just we
were [ __ ] wasted you know just kind
of like doing the Arsenio yeah can you
get to AI and play music
only if you sir I'm still trying he's
always what did you say so you said you
want to get so high you don't even know
what's court your pleasure yeah I know a
song where players like yeah no the
problem is like we get so high when we
record that and then we have to remember
that live or relearn it and then if you
get high live you can't remember what
you played high when you record that is
an issue so then you go back and listen
to recordings and go what yeah I mean we
had to look I had to go back after
before rehearsals this was a really
weird thing has never happened
I went from mixing and like
sussing looking at this film for the
past year - now we have to learn these
songs so your fight you're actually like
paying attention to what you did their
play these chords I was like wow [ __ ]
did I do that you know just so weird
that we did it so relatively quick
quicker than the other stuff that we did
[ __ ] you know we yeah we had to learn it
all over again
because I did we didn't remember doing
any of it it was just so creative and
quick like that they hadn't heard any of
the songs since we recorded them until I
sent him the record three weeks ago
yeah yeah is it surreal going listen to
all of it after it's all pieced together
a little bit yeah yeah for me it was
yeah yeah looks like riding a bike
though really you know especially not
playing in a year we know each other you
know just jump back on yeah I'm still
catching things and the recordings that
I have don't play live I'll hear little
bits and things still so Wow
I got a question when you're when you're
in the studio with them are you in
producer mode because you've produced
other artists or you kind of are they
kind of producers with you and you guys
are finding it together oh man I
couldn't I couldn't tell these guys to
do what they do
why would I mean I don't want to work
with you I want to work with the guys
that just do [ __ ] that amazes me but no
I'm not like I have a rough structure in
my head of what what it sounds like you
know they're I guess I don't know you
might maybe you guys should answer that
question yeah I mean you said it but you
have an idea of what you want but you
you kind of give us the reins
yeah tell them tell us you know like an
opportunity to not [ __ ] up like you know
a wu-tang vibe or so yeah and then you
know boo Tang why
so there's definitely I have liked the
idea of the sound I'm chasing and it's
hard to articulate mm-hmm but with this
it was just I realized like maybe by the
end of the second day we were doing
something I know I hadn't really heard
before
or maybe I was hearing like 15 of my
favorite records all at the same time I
was just like okay this is what this is
gonna be and it's probably gonna destroy
my career and that's a better
this is [ __ ] I like it
[Applause]